there's currently renewed energy you
could say for coal power in the United
States most of it is from the new
administration in the White House and
I've talked countless times about how
this makes no sense at all I mean truly
it makes no sense the same people that
say they want the market to decide are
trying to save an industry that is
increasingly increasingly not viable
anymore forget about the fact that
Arby's employs more people than the
entire coal industry in the United
States and ignore for a second that coal
is horribly polluting and not
financially efficient Donald Trump still
wants to save coal and we've now learned
more about how great it would be to kill
coal a new study that's been conducted
by a team from Michigan Tech University
reveals that if the United States
eliminated coal and transitioned all
coal to solar energy you would save
approximately 52,000 lives per year and
you would pump endless amounts of money
into our economy every year tens of
thousands of people in the US die
prematurely from air pollution related
diseases associated with the burning of
coal we have a map for people who are
watching with us which correlates
coal-fired electricity to deaths related
from air pollution and the World Health
Organization has said that air pollution
is the biggest cause of non communicable
disease in the world that includes
stroke cancer chronic respiratory
illnesses and heart disease and the
study found that indeed 52,000 premature
deaths could be prevented every year if
we stopped producing electricity with
coal and replaced it with solar power
but those are only the health benefits
not only are there health benefits but
switching to solar would also be really
good for the American economy of the
2,000 of the 52,000 deaths prevented the
scientists at Michigan Tech found that
switching to solar would generate two
and a half million dollars for each
death that you prevent Joshua piers
who's a professor of material science
and electrical engineering at Michigan
Tech says quote unlike other
Kalvin vestments you get more than live
saved in addition to saving lives solar
is producing electricity which has
economic value everyone wants to avoid
wasting money just based off the pure
value of electricity of the
sensitivities we looked at its
profitable to save American lives by
eliminating coal wood solar using data
from peer-reviewed journals the EPA and
the Department of Energy they also use
current costs of solar plants and
calculated the potential return on
investment to come up with these numbers
completely replacing all solar all coal
plants rather in the US with solar
photovoltaics would require 755
gigawatts of solar power that's compared
to the 22.7 gigawatts of solar we
currently have that would cost a
trillion and a half dollars so when you
see that you say wow David that sounds
insanely expensive the 1.5 trillion
would pale in comparison to how much
money would be made off of the solar
plants and saved with the solar plants
much more profitable than coal which is
naturally dying out one more quote from
the Michigan Tech professor quote Solar
has come down radically in cost it's
technically viable and coupled with
natural gas plants other renewables and
storage we have ways to produce all the
electricity we need without coal period
my overall takeaway from the study is
that if we're rational and we care about
American lives or even just money then
it's time to end coal in the United
States isn't Trump the business guy
isn't he going to make great deals doing
this in the u.s. transitioning from coal
to solar would not only help Americans
in terms of health that's a pretty good
deal it would help people all over the
world in terms of health because
pollution doesn't exactly respect
imaginary lines on maps but it also
would be so great for the economy and
yet Donald Trump is against it Pat yeah
of course Trump does claim to be a great
business guy but he also is great at
appealing to a crowd yeah and you know
putting profitability aside putting the
effects on the climate aside there's a
lot of people who
work in these coal mines and they've
been doing it for generations and they
want to hold on to it because it's a
noble job for them and despite the fact
that they may have negative health
consequences down the road they just
have always been doing it they live in a
coal town they come from a coal family I
get it that's a hard thing to argue
again I get it and the lost jobs are a
problem and it's something that would
have a negative economic impact and that
has to be considered but again fewer
jobs than RVs in the entire coal
industry in the United States and we
should be critical consumers of all
Meuse and reports even like the one I
just told you about the study misses a
few things it doesn't consider as I
mentioned the cost of the lost coal jobs
it doesn't consider that then those
people who lose their coal jobs don't
have money to spend in the economy that
has to be subtracted out solar
installations currently use a lot of
copper and copper mining is related to
some pretty significant environmental
disasters and you would need copper for
the solar installations you do have to
subtract out all of those things but the
benefits are overwhelming here I mean it
just sounds like a win-win-win to me not
only is it profitable not only is it
good for the environment it also helps
people with the negative health
consequences things like black lung
wouldn't be nearly as big of an issue as
they are now it's time to kill coal the
numbers say it it's abundantly clear and
yet the president wants to do the
opposite Low Energy sad I'm thrilled to
tell you that today's episode is made
possible in part by taga dabbe the
hosting specialists offering a broad
range of affordable and flexible hosting
packages this includes dedicated server
packages virtual private server cloud
server custom server solutions
colocation services tag adapt currently
has an average Trustpilot review rating
of excellent at nine point seven out of
ten and part of this must be because
they've have hosting experts who are
also providing the tech support you can
actually get insight and advice and
support from the people who know what
they're talking about
currently taga dad is offering david
pakman show viewers a ten British Pound
Credit about twelve or thirteen US
dollars to try their cloud server
solutions at signup tag adavi
/td PS